salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor
aujourd'hui on est encore en compagnie
de Wim de Dani de Jade et de rasta et
syiddney qui sont là et
là-bas et aujourd'hui on a quelque chose
de spécial aussi parce que wi nous a
amené un un nouvel ément un ément
particulier un wi me magnet un ément
d'éolienne ouis prê et on le teste tout
de suite par que quandtin a quelque
chose
avec oh ohce que c'est je sais pas
coin pas la barrière parce qu'il est
costaud celui-là
ouais regardez comme il est il est
carré et il est puissant parce que
parce que ça marche bien ça ça marche
fort ça vraiment différent look du
barbian c'est pas vraiment 360 je crois
ouais çaattrape sur le côté devant
peut-être pas en haut il est sympa ton
nouveau tatou merci c'est j tu me l'as
fait Nice gift Nice gift thank you gift
a offert un aimant très puissant allez
le petit lancé d'im
d'éolienne ça vole bien quand même ça
ouais ouais ça do bien rentrer dans la
vase parfait pour les coins comme ça qui
ont sûrement déjà été fait en plus en cé
on commence on vair ce qu'on arrive à
trouver premier lancé
de il a déjà première
trouvaille avec du cuivre une bobine un
bout de tube super ça commence bien ah
co trouvé une pièce aussi ok 1 centime
ok j'ai quelque chose
ou
là
[Musique]
d'accord on va vous montrer la taille du
truc
ok on a quelque
chose oh qu'est-ce que
c'est ah
d'accord c'est petite lumière de
scooter peut-être que le scooter aussi à
l'intérieur on va essayer de le trouver
désolé un peu de
vent oui je vous rappelle du coup cette
vidéo sera surtout en français mais
aussi un petit peu en
Deutch en
anglais panneau
d'escalier
super
OK
inér encore une forme de Bill on a
trouvé la même quelques jours emble
c'est rigoloutre beaucoup avoir cere de
en commentaire vous
l'avez de pas vous la faire piquer comme
comme s personn Quentin pêche avec un
d'éolienne est de tester
ça
bon allez ma première trouvaille de la
journée avec le nouvel aant
oh une échelle là c'est un étendir
ok on a quelque
chose qu'est-ce que
c'est un gros pot
d'échappement un vieux pot
d'échappement ah oui j'ai ça lâcher sin
avec un autre c
çaess
làâ le pire scénario cétais
sû bien
joué on essaie de retrouver
c'est
OKCs la droite
pour un sac accroché un
siègeconter carment sur la terre de pas
per
OK
[Applaudissements]
on
t'attend tu veux que t' peu en même
[Applaudissements]
temps
ok alors yeux c'est de la mousse jaune à
l'intérieurant commentaire en attendant
nous on va ouvrir le sac avant que
celuià c'est
bon le
sac il y a une poche aussi derrière ah
mais elle est
ouverte absolument
rien
non has new bag mais un nouveau sac Jade
génial il est
super je vais essayer par en dessous
attends belle
t tot r
OK
super
non ça n'a aucun
sens pourquoi trouver ça ici regardez il
a tout pris sur ses jambes il s'en fiche
en même temps il y a quelques temps il
était dans les cours d'eau en train de
plonger la tête dedans donc c'est pas un
peu de bout dans les pieds qui vont
gêner mais joli désolé pour le vent il a
l'air de bien marcher cet aent ça va
hein une sorte de un pédalier pédalier
ouais mais ah non de truil non ah non
non c'est un truc de M je pense ouais
bien
joué ah oui de C 4 je pense ouais ouais
bien joué regz la qui remamène un CAD
toute
seule bravo on va pouvoir mettre tout
découvertes à
l'intérieur bien
joué bien
j comme ça on les découvert
dedans sympa bien joué oua j' encore
quelque chose pour l'instant c'estelle
qui fait le plus de trouvaille avec
petit
terror c'est quoi ça un sapin de Noël
nonoui ok bah
sympa oh c'est
lourd oh une
échelle c'est l'ancienne échelle qui
était làbas là j'ai un gros
truc bien
lourd
j'ai besoin d'aide bat ça a l'air
massiftin est toujours là-bas il galère
sur un truc il est recoincé je vais
aller l'aider
j'arrive c'est presque fait sol mais un
scooter non ouais
peut-être ouais ça paraît plus massif tu
as
vu un peu moins lourd oh un
rail au bout ça pour être massif c'est
massif comme les Chimé comme ça ouais la
prof que l'ment ou la puissance du truc
sû du imaginez la puissance de l'ément
là comme ça juste sur c'est
incroyable
bon d'ailleurs regardez j'ai ressorti le
PO de l'ancien logo ou parce que tu as
perdu tes t-shirt surtout parce qu'on
pêche tellement qu'ils sont tous sales
et ça c'était quand on avait dans les 4
5000 abonn peut-être 10000 maximum c'est
les polos noroto donc si vous vous
rappelez de ça ouais on se moquit de
nous parce qu'il disait qu'on avait des
polos noroto ou car glace non car glace
non ouais car bon j'ai quelque
chose est perdu attends unent attends
attends il juste
là souvent c'est vers la montée qui se
bloque en dirit j'ai pas compris
pourquoi en plus parce qu'il avait l'air
bienenté c'est encore plein ouais il a
encore plein de choses c'est ouf
d'accord en plus c'est la grosse ferrar
ouais donc c'est possible de trouver les
ouais
j'avoue on va voir ce que j'ai
ok tropoxyde d'azote comme quand même
dans les coins paumés même ici on en
trouve
oh un
sac voir ce qu'il y a dedans
ah
ok c juste une ceinture de
sécurité ok allez j'ai quelque
chose juste en bas de la pente on va
voir ce qu'ils ont jeté ici
ou là une
trottinette
parfait parfait parfait parfait mais je
pensais pas en trouver une ici mais
comme quoi on peut vraiment en trouver
de partout des trottinettes c'est
vraiment l'objet qu'on trouve le plus en
pêchealment en ce moment ok quelque
chose ah ben c'est l'autre ceinture de
sécurité voilà
parfait a quelque chose de l'autre côté
du pont on va essayer de le filmer par
là une télé
non ah ouais c'est de voiture ça l' très
peuenté très
fin bon ils ont sorti un bout de
carrosserie moi j'ai peut-être a
récupéré l'objet qui faisait que
retomber là-bas on va voir ah
oui un
panneau il est pas
aenté c'est de
l'AL oh il a eu un accident de voiture
lui aussi la pause repas avec les deux
animaux à qure pattes un peu
intéressé et moi j'ai peut-être quelque
chose pendant ce temps on va voir si ça
va être la trouvaille qui va me
permettre de prendre ma pause repas et
ben j'ai pas l'impression hein c'est un
truc de Chario hein peut-être qu'il y a
un à l'intérieur on espère
tous même pas je v lui parler français
[Rires]
on l'a eu on l'a
eu
quelque
chose ok le deuxè siège ça cétait
ok je
l'ai perf
ça viens
oh ah non po d'échappement
ok
magnet pas mal pour le
fer un téléphone allemand
téléphone ah ouais ok c'est un téléphone
chip sûement téléphone de encore une
fois il jette après s être servi
quelques jours c'est toujours
intéressant c'est bon signe ça montre
qu'il a quand même des délincants qui
passent par là même si c'est un c un peu
paumé
donc ah j'ai quelque chose de jaune
qutin tu vois ce que
c'est
non c'est un cutter mais s
L le gazilarant TR toxique et ouais
c'est la deuxième qu'on fait ici bon
voilà il reste pas grand chose sous ce
spot même s'il y a des morceaux qui
attrapent ils accrochent pas bien c'est
galère moi j'ai fait 10 aimants vid là
donc j'en ai marre on va changer de pont
je vais toujours tester cet aiment donc
c'est parti ouais on va faire un
deuxième spot on a pas mal de POS en
tête et et voilà on emmène encore Wim et
Dani avec nous n'hésitez pas à regarder
la chaîne de wiim qui est en description
de la vidéo il sort du lourd il pêche à
Bruxelles molenbeak et underlecht si je
prononce bien cette fois dites-moi bel
en commentaire ne me criez pas dessus je
crois que c'est Molen B mol mol
oui il disait à la téléand il y avait
les djihadistes mais non il disait AC
l'accent français justement il même bah
dites-nous en commentaire les vrais
belges et comme d'habitude on récupère
toute la ferraille elle sera vendu au
poids chez le
ferrailleur et Dani a une
chaise
bien
joué truc quelque
chose non pas ici ah non c'est pas du
protoxy
d'AZ pour une fois c'est une arme
pistoletist el chose
oh un arbre et un boîtier
étrange regarder ce que c'est un disque
dur peut-être
ok l'arbre est retourné dans l'eau ah
non c'est une
cassette dans sa boîte ouais peut-être
on va regarder je crois qu'on va voir ce
qu'il y a dessus
cassette vidé
[Musique]
cassettevrir ce que
c'est OK
yes adap
adap
ok un camescope ouis ouais j'ai vu aussi
a eu un camescope mais il est
retombé la cassette camera j'ai un truc
lourd ou je crois que ça bouge on est
sur le même ouais je crois qu'on est sur
la même chose non
ouais moi j'ai mon canescope c'est super
lourd c'est voiture ça to de la voiture
on sort comme ça on pourra s le CAMC
après juste avec des
[Musique]
câbles
déjà fatigué sacré morceau de voiture on
va essayer de de continuer il doit en
avoir d'autres je vais continuer à
lancer par là il y avait plein d'objets
mais ah il y en a plein qui viennent pas
il vont finir par
venir donc là j'ai eu quelque
chose enfin j'ai envie dire j'ai un
petit pistolet à peinture
ohed ouied
ok ok
merci ok donc ça pi dire qu' peuttre des
coffres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fort
[Musique]
as
raison il dit qu'il y avait des choses
dedans incroyable on est abonné au sac
d'outil
cool une montre
Apple Apple
non ch
ok
Samsung ah merci jade je su
contenta qu'est-ce qu'il en pense cont
content plus ou
moins c'est
lourd
ok
t
ah
ouaisokore Magné magque ou
pas tu veux je te grave elle est trop
belle tu peux la garder un diamant
dessus
M
regarde toujours derrière pense un
Galaxy S4 c'est vieux
okation 2020 je crois c'est le début du
COD voil
okéussi faire
marcherenyé images d'ailleurs on a déjà
envoyé des des outils qu'on a pêché en
réparation et il avait réussi refa
marcher
une
[Musique]
bague c'est de l'argent c'est de
l'argent
l'argent de l'argent s925 ça veut dire
que c'est de l'argent mais qu'il a été
doré en fait super
super cool voir
bravo
Baptiste ta chéri ouais bah dites-nous
en commentaire à qui vous voulez que je
l'offre du coup tuelle sur
préféré tu as déjà eu la boucle
d'oreille c'est vrai fallait attendre
voir ce qu'il y avait dedans d' au li on
fera la montre connecté
aussi incroyable vous avez vu on trouve
un sac d'outil et à l'intérieur une
boucle d'oreilles en argent et cette
magnifique bague qui est aussi en argent
et plaqué or avec des brillants donc
peut-être destit petit diamant aussi on
sait
jamais
wou regarde Quentin c'est peut-être même
pas émenté en plus c'est coincé dans le
truc ah encore un bijou de femme ouais
regarde attends on va voir s'il
estmenté mais pas ça ouais un peu et
tuas une boule de aussi tu en a deux non
c'est une bou de ça tu crois en plus
c'est ensemble c'est une seu boule
d'oreill c'est une boule d'oreill
ouabe